what's up Mafia I'm Eric and I'm doing
the wired autocomplete interview
it's not your business
just for the record
[Music]
all right what Eric what does Eric mean
that's an interesting question basically
when I was like 13 Instagram was
invented and I was trying to get at Eric
E r i c which is my first name but
obviously that wasn't available so I
just kind of kept respelling Eric in the
most interesting and idiotic ways
possible a 13 year old Eric came up with
air rack and now I'm stuck with it for
life what did Eric do before YouTube I
would go around to different businesses
and shoot whatever somebody would pay me
to pick up a camera to do I would
basically do it what happened to arak I
feel like it's going to be something
about me dying or something what
happened to Eric's Channel I think this
might be talking about the time that I
accidentally deleted my YouTube channel
I was trying to change the settings on
my channel one time and I accidentally
pressed the delete channel button which
uh sent YouTube into what they called
code black which means that everybody at
the entire YouTube organization all the
executives had to try to restore my
channel immediately that wasn't like a
year ago or something like that while
the channel was down I actually ended up
pretending like I purposely deleted the
channel I made a video just promoting
this YouTuber ping pong competition that
I had up but yeah 24 hours later Susan
and the Gang ended up getting my YouTube
channel back up so thank you Susan I owe
you one what Eric video got taken down
this is a Whopper of a story right here
when I had like 20 000 subscribers I had
this video idea to sneak into a Dan
Bilzerian party if you don't know who
Dan Bilzerian is he's like the ultimate
manly man he has like 30 million
followers on Instagram he just posts
pictures of him with hot babes every day
he threw a party that he only invited a
thousand of the most influential people
and then just a bunch of the hottest
women on earth so I thought it would be
funny if I snuck into the party to show
everybody what's going on so I did and I
like hid in the bushes for like four
hours and then snuck into the party and
filmed the entire thing uploaded it to
YouTube it was like my first viral video
I remember it got like 85 000 views in
an hour which at the time was like an
unbelievable amount of views literally
within the hour uh Dan bilzerian's team
got back to me said take the video down
or else I didn't take the video down and
then three days later a guy in a suit
showed up to my front door and served me
papers and said I had three days to take
the video down or I was going to get
charged a quarter of a million dollars
plus all of his legal fees and at the
time I had 20 000 subscribers so I was
terrified and I just took the video down
Dan let me know if you ever want to make
amends I'm not mad at you what is Eric
outro song My outro song is called Bad
Karma by Axel theslev shout out Axel I
started using the song and then his
management actually copyright striked
all my videos so I dm'd him on Instagram
and he ended up whitelisting my channel
so that I can use his song forever so
shout out to Axel you're the man it's
like a frisbee when Eric when did Eric
start YouTube I actually started YouTube
in the fifth grade I think that was like
in
2006. I found out from a friend at
school that YouTube existed and then
that night took my parents like tape
camera and found like 20 dongles that
allowed me to tape something on a camera
plug it into my computer get the footage
off of it and then upload it to YouTube
and it sounds like totally normal now
because we have like Tick Tock and
smartphones and everything but at the
time filming on tape and then getting it
onto the internet where anybody with a
connection to the internet could watch a
video was like an insane thought but I
actually started trying to like become a
YouTuber about three years ago but I
always wanted to be a YouTuber since I
was a little kid when does Eric post so
I try to post every week logistically a
lot of these videos are kind of a
nightmare to produce so like for example
a year ago I tried to rent out an entire
commercial airliner but it turns out the
guy that I rented the plane from he was
actually a scammer like he didn't have
any planes at all so I had like me and a
hundred of my friends out on a Tarmac in
Florida in like the heat of Summer and
the plane just never came I had to go
back get a lawsuit against them to try
to get the money back finally got the
money back like a month later then I had
to take that money find a real guy to
give me a real plane got all my 100
friends back to the same airport got
onto the airplane shot the video edited
the video and posted the video
but that took like two months so these
are the things that sometimes keep me
from uploading videos on a weekly basis
when did Eric hit 10 million subscribers
so my goal when I started YouTube like
three years ago was to go from zero to a
million subscribers in a year which we
did the next year last year we went from
1 million to like 4 million subscribers
and then in 2022 we went from 4 million
subscribers to 10 million subscribers
and I promised my fans that at the end
of the year I would throw the world's
largest pizza party and we actually set
the world record for the world's largest
pizza and threw a giant pizza party for
myself and the mafia to celebrate
hitting 10 million subscribers it was
beautiful
oh man how Iraq how blank Eric have
interesting how many subscribers does
arak have we just hit 12 million
subscribers which is crazy how did Eric
get his scar I have never answered this
question before that's a great question
so I have a scar right here on my neck
I've actually named it Bubblicious just
a random name I came up with I actually
had a tumor in my neck like if you look
at old photos of me on Instagram you'll
see like this huge bump coming out of my
neck right here and it was like right
when I was about to start doing YouTube
so before I got put to sleep on
anesthesia I told the doctor hey my man
I'm gonna start doing YouTube and I'm
like gonna be a big YouTuber so like try
to make the scar as small as possible
and he laughed at me and then I woke up
and the scar was like three inches wide
I was so mad he told me it was gonna be
like an inch it was so big don't go to
that guy I wish I knew his name I would
tell you guys not to go to him right now
how much does Eric make off of what you
know you got to be specific here is my
mom here I don't really tell her these
kinds of questions the answer is
Millions I wish this was followed up by
another question how much does Air Act
spend because the answer to that would
be also Millions you watch my videos you
know I've been wearing this hoodie for
like two years I have the same car that
I've been driving for like five years
and I somehow make
but also spend millions of dollars on
these stupid videos shout out to the
mafia you're welcome I do it for you
guys how many bodyguards does Eric have
zero uh zero bodyguards I had this idea
of what would happen if I hired 50
bodyguards so I hired 50 bodyguards I
went around La I got into the back room
of Nobu with my bodyguards I got a
immediate reservation at Saddle Ranch I
took my bodyguards to the Venice Beach
gym and kicked all the giant
bodybuilders off the equipment so that I
could work out I also did a video like
six months ago where I hired 100
bodyguards and then I used those to
sneak into VidCon I'm now permanently
banned from ever going back to VidCon I
don't know why I did that I thought it'd
be funny I'm sorry VidCon I shouldn't
have done that probably
here we go next one does Eric cuss I
don't cuss that much honestly if I cuss
right now will you guys bleep it no
does Eric fake videos this question
triggers me because of the lengths that
we go to to make sure that videos are
not faked unscripted completely real
will like reshoot entire videos we have
people living in separate houses so that
information isn't shared between myself
and my friends like we go so far to make
sure that videos are not fixed so no you
can count on me to not fake videos
unlike almost every other Creator on the
platform I just feel like I just started
100 beefs not sorry about it does Eric
have a world record I've attempted like
three or four different world record
I've attempted most eggs smashed with
head in one minute I've attempted uh
most snails on the face I've only
actually accomplished one world record
which was creating the world's largest
pizza does Eric have a tattoo I have a
tattoo I don't think I've ever shown
this before under my watch you would
think I'm a clean-cut guy no tattoos
here when I was 17 my biggest
inspiration on Earth was Casey neistat I
was on a Venice Beach with my cousin and
Jack and Jack and I got matching tattoos
on our wrists that say do more always
empty the tank
do the most that you possibly can does
Eric live with his parents who's
searching this you know like who of you
is searching whether or not I live with
my parents the answer is no I don't live
with my parents I'm from a small town
called coming Georgia spelled
c-u-m-m-i-n-g it's not a joke it's a
real place and my parents live there
um I probably shouldn't tell people that
but it is what it is so sorry Mom and
Dad okay next question
did Eric almost become Spider-Man I've
always wanted to be in like a Spider-Man
movie I I thought for sure the direction
of my life was going to be the next
Spider-Man when I was a kid so I climbed
to the side of a building in LA and put
my phone number at the top of it to try
to get the attention of all of the
Marvel execs so that they would call me
and I actually ended up getting a call
with somebody from Marvel I think it was
like a Pity call to be honest with you I
think they were just trying to make me
feel like I had a shot they asked me
about why I like Spider-Man so much what
makes me a good fit to be Spider-Man and
then they said they would get back to me
and that was like nine months ago
so did Eric actually go to space I think
I was the first person ever to eat pizza
in zero gravity so I took a zero gravity
plane where they just go up and down
really fast and I brought pizza with me
and it was just me and my friend Mack
eating pizza and zero gravity turns out
when you eat in zero gravity your body
does not know what to do with the food
so you just start violently vomiting
everywhere I would know
because I puked pizza for an hour and a
half straight and it cost twenty
thousand dollars did Eric break his
collarbone the answer to that is no but
something interesting about me that most
people probably wouldn't expect because
of my reckless lifestyle is that I've
actually never broken a bone in my
entire life not a single bone I'm kind
of shocked by that fact I feel like I
should have broken something by now did
Eric die did Eric die
really I've actually thought about
making a video where I faked my own
death a lot of times did Eric win a
streaming yes I did I actually hosted
the Streamys this year which was a
really interesting experience and I came
home with two streaming Awards uh one is
the creator honor award and the other
one was best first person creator of the
year you is Eric is Eric a mafia leader
if the police are asking no but yes I
started calling my fan base the mafia
early early on I had a really ambitious
goal of going from zero to a million
subscribers in one year which was like
completely never done before and the way
that I would get people's attention was
by like sending the mafia after these
people and it started what we still have
which is like this deadly
cultish group of people who at any point
in time at my whim I can just
send them after somebody for better for
worse is Eric a good YouTuber I mean in
my opinion I'm the best YouTuber that's
ever lived but I feel like that's kind
of up to the to the audience is Eric's
dad pewdiepie So I do this bit in the
videos where I always refer to my dad
being PewDiePie because PewDiePie you
know has always been like the biggest
YouTuber until Mr Beast overtook him but
before that he's been the biggest
YouTuber on the platform for so long and
that's my aspiration as well so I've
referred to PewDiePie as my dad because
he's a huge inspiration but he's not
actually my biological dad is Eric
family friendly
um
if I were to rank my videos on like a
normal movie scale it's probably PG-13
it's not R it's definitely not g I would
say it's like PG-13 is Eric related to
Mr Beast that's a funny question Jimmy
and I are not related to each other I
don't think we look anything alike
something interesting about Jimmy is
that where Jimmy lives and where I grew
up is like a three-hour drive but we
didn't know that we lived near each
other until we both became YouTubers and
started talking to each other I think
when I hit like a million subscribers
Jimmy hit me up on Twitter and was like
yo let's get on a call it just sends me
his phone number so we started talking
and then we became pretty good friends
after that what's interesting to me was
that I moved to LA because I thought
that you had to live in LA to become a
successful YouTuber meanwhile Jimmy
lives literally in the middle of the
Appalachian Mountains and this dude has
become the world's biggest YouTuber so I
think that just goes to show that you
can start from anywhere and make it is
Eric the fastest growing YouTuber I
probably was the fastest growing
YouTuber to go from zero to a million
we're gaining like
five to five hundred thousand to like a
million subscribers a month so I don't
know you guys should check socialblade
and tell me if I'm the fastest growing
YouTuber it might accidentally be doing
that
Eric biggest secret I did a video where
my boys and I all revealed our biggest
secrets on on camera but mine was
blurred so the audience never actually
got to see what my biggest secret was I
might reveal it in a video but not in
this video not in this video and not
today Eric's sneaking in oh man I have a
long history with sneaking in to events
it's like my favorite thing to do I did
it before YouTube and now it's just
completely gotten out of hand I'll be
honest on YouTube it started I was
sneaking into local music festivals like
in my town with different disguises and
stuff like that I ended up sneaking into
rolling loud five times in one day as
like a construction worker an artist all
kinds of disguises that I would come up
to sneak into these music festivals Eric
Bermuda Triangle I went there one time I
have a problem where I get extremely
extremely seasick and to just be
completely honest with you guys I went
out there in a life raft spent 24 hours
in it puked the entire time and I was
just laying in my own vomit for for like
24 hours if you guys include that in the
interview I will be shocked that is a
vile story Eric extreme Capture the Flag
so my idea was to play Capture the Flag
out in the open in real life and let
real people be a part of it we went out
into the streets of Santa Monica with
golf carts and played a four-person
capture the flag for an entire day for
me personally it was like one of the
most fun experiences of my life Eric
don't laugh try not to laugh is a trend
that's been happening on YouTube for
like since the Inception of the platform
so my idea was to get my friends
together and schedule an entire day out
where we play try not to laugh in real
life it was super super funny yeah Eric
breaking 100 laws so I remember when I
was a kid I had this book of all these
weird laws that were apparently real for
example it's illegal to Eat Fried
Chicken past two o'clock in Alabama so I
had this idea to take these laws and
then break all of them in one day so we
started by jumping off the Santa Monica
Pier which wasn't actually that weird of
a law it just actually makes sense to
not do that but then we broke like a
hundred weird laws that day we ended up
sneaking into an abandoned Hospital
getting caught by the cops almost going
to jail anything for the video you know
that's the end of my interview I'm
flattered that you guys Googled all
these things about me you guys are
pretty nosy asking me how much money I
make I'm not asking you how much money
you make maybe you know mind your own
business a little bit
[Music]